Despite being a company which prides itself
on making kids' movies, Disney is responsible
for some of the most disturbing death scenes
in cinema history.
From tragic family loss to straight-up body
horror, these are the Disney deaths that traumatized
us as children.
Considering so many Disney characters tend
to be orphans, The Lion King’s Simba could
be counted as lucky, this little lion cub
has got a loving mom and his father Mufasa
is protective, gentle and understanding.
Until he gets trampled to death, that is.
In the film's darkest moment, Simba finds
himself trapped in a gorge, desperately trying
to outrun a herd of stampeding wildebeest.
Just when it looks like he’s going to wind
up as a Pride Land pancake, Mufasa comes to
the rescue, leaping into the horde of hooves
and horns to save his kid.
But while Mufasa gets Simba to safety, climbing
out of the gorge proves to be too difficult
for the mighty king.
Fortunately, his dear old brother Scar is
there to help.
“Long live the king.”
While the film makes clear that Mufasa has
never been on great terms with his brother,
there’s still a look of genuine betrayal
on his face when Scar tosses him down to his
doom.
But the real heartache comes when Simba tries
to get his dad to wake up, nuzzling his lifeless
body before finally relenting and heading
into exile.
Back in 1994, between the 1967 animated classic
and the 2016 remake, Disney released a live-action
version of The Jungle Book.
The plot of the film has Mowgli forced to
lead a band of British soldiers to a stash
of hidden treasure.
But as Mowgli and his sadistic captors head
into the jungle, this PG kids' flick slowly
transforms into a genuine horror movie.
One villain falls from a cliff, another is
mauled by a tiger, while the big bad eventually
ends up in a watery grave, before being finished
off by a gigantic python.
At one point, a British bully falls into a
pit of quicksand, and, despite his friends'
best efforts, slowly sinks into the muck,
crying in terror all the way down.
Another baddie finds himself caught in a temple
tramp, left helpless as the roof seals shut
and the room fills with sand, entombing him
for all eternity.
Not exactly the bare necessities, is it?
Despite the occasional moment of levity, The
Hunchback of Notre Dame isn’t afraid to
get dark.
With that said, it should come as no surprise
that when the villainous Claude Frollo meets
his end, it comes in the most disturbing way
possible.
In the film's big finale, Frollo is chasing
the hunchback Quasimodo and his love Esmeralda
through the halls of Notre Dame, hoping to
catch and kill the object of his desire.
The chase eventually leads to the cathedral's
balcony, and after a brief showdown, this
happens:
Even kids can probably understand the hellish
metaphor on display here, and while Frollo
does deserve his fate, watching him fall into
the flames is still enough to make anyone
fear for their immortal soul.
The folks at Disney know there's nothing scarier
for a kid than the idea that their mom could
die.
That’s one of the reasons why Bambi is basically
the saddest animated movie ever made, and,
over sixty years later, Pixar followed in
Bambi's hoof prints by traumatizing a whole
new generation with Finding Nemo.
The movie opens on a hopeful note, with expectant
parents Marlin and Coral moving into their
oceanfront anemone home.
The two clownfish have over 400 little eggs
waiting to hatch, and they couldn't be more
excited about their future.
That's when Marlin notices an approaching
barracuda, staring straight at the parents
and their unhatched kids.
When the barracuda moves in for the kill,
Marlin does his best to ward off the beast,
but is knocked unconscious.
When he wakes up, Coral is gone, and every
egg save one has been devoured.
Although we don't actually see anyone get
eaten, we do see poor Marlin mourn his dead
wife and unborn children.
His heartbreaking sobs, coupled with the idea
you really could lose your mom at any moment,
would have made so many kids feel completely
adrift while watching the movie.
Davy Jones is arguably one of the great Disney
villains, thanks in large part to a CGI face
that still looks amazing years after his appearance
in the Pirates of the Caribbean sequels.
With his lobster hand, tentacled chin and
supernatural crew, Jones was a force to be
reckoned with, until the East India Trading
Company got hold of his heart.
Stashed away in a wooden chest, the heart
gives the villainous Cutler Beckett and his
henchman Ian Mercer the ability to control
the pirate lord.
Near the end of Pirates of the Caribbean:
At World's End, however, Mercer finds out
why you should never play with a buccaneer's
heart.
During the film’s climactic sea battle,
a cannonball kills Mercer's men, leaving him
alone with the octopus pirate.
Seizing the chance to reclaim his heart, Jones
kills Mercer in the slimiest, gruesomest way
possible.
It honestly might be the most gruesome death
in any Disney film ever.